Viennese Waltz from Dancing with the
Stars give it up for Sascha farmer and
Ally Brook give up forever to touch you
cause I know that you feel me somehow
you're the closest to heaven that I'll
ever be I don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we you were both good god that was so
great how's Ali been doing she is
literally a dream Padma she comes in so
dedicated her passion I mean I've known
Natalie for a while now and maybe two or
three years ago I saw at the Grove and I
was like that's Ali and I ran up to her
and I was like we would be perfect and
dancing okay can you show me and Mike
some of your moves I want to so we're
gonna be knees walls so we're gonna do
the opposite of me right so we're gonna
step two you're gonna step that way yes
and we're gonna step this way so we're
gonna go one two three old change look
at that one two three look at this okay
that's pretty good
[Music]
let's do two of those okay okay Bri nice
got that pretty dagger I grew up a
musical theater there we go one two
three two
[Applause]
okay and then from there I'm gonna
demonstrate with Ali she's gonna go from
the last one she's gonna step through
this big finish big finish so let's go
from the beginning but yeah okay we need
applause come on guys yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
nice an economy change
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this